[Musica]
arrivo lucchi tutti a casa
si accascia e chiunque
amica
[Musica]
new ma serve più
maggiore modo a miè insomma la mia il
suo mare mi perdo
[Musica]
amore
purtroppo un budget
m.te
[Musica]
margio trova ad uomini suo amore niente
più amare per tu cambia il suo amore
alla parola
[Musica]
bene
grazie
dovuto cominciare con la musica e con un
brano che in qualche modo è strettamente
connesso a quello che vorrei raccontarvi
stasera è un brano che parla come avete
sentito del perdersi
e quindi cominciamo subito con
una domanda a proposito appunto del
perdersi
volevo chiedervi per cominciare
qual è secondo voi il labirinto più
intricato
qual è il labirinto più intricato di
fronte al quale vi siete trovati o in
mezzo al quale vi siete trovati qual è
il labirinto nel quale vi siete sentiti
più smarriti
io da piccolo era un po appassionato di
enigmistica e mi soffermavo molto spesso
sulla settimana enigmistica non so se vi
ricordate quei labirinti di varie forme
in cui bisognava trovare la strada che
sono sempre molto divertito a farli
quando lo piccolo cominciamo con la
matita scrivevo facevo i percorsi ma
dopo un po mi dava molto fastidio il
fatto che questa matita poi segnasse dei
vicoli ciechi no allora dovessi poi
ritornare a riscrivere e si creava una
sorta di pastrocchio che e quindi mi
fermavo molto più tempo ad osservare
questo labirinto e con la mente e con
gli occhi a seguire le varie linee che
mi portavano fuori fino a quando non
trovavo
quella giusta e allora li segnavo con la
matita la fine del labirinto ma poi da
più grande mi sono trovato
improvvisamente senza nessun preavviso
in mezzo ad un labirinto veramente
intricato
proprio senza preavviso cioè mi sono
alzato una mattina e adesso vi dico dove
almeno teseo pensavo
sapeva di entrare in un labirinto ma
almeno arianna aveva avuto qualche tempo
per elaborare un escamotage questo
famoso filo che poteva servire poi come
trucchetto per uscire dal labirinto
teniamolo a mente questo filo perché
magari poi potrebbe servire anche a noi
nel caso dovessimo condividere questo
questa esperienza
insomma la mattina mi trovavo su un
motoveliero in mezzo all'adriatico
mi sono svegliato all'alba era la prima
notte di navigazione poi vi racconterò
il perché di questo viaggio ma vorrei
partire così sono uscito fuori e mi sono
guardato intorno
intorno a me non c'era nulla
era bellissima carità primo pensiero
fantastico
risveglio memorabile secondo pensiero
dove sono
mi sono reso conto che quello
quell'essere in mezzo al mare lontano e
privo di ogni riferimento
era il labirinto più intricato
non sapevo dov'ero
non conoscevo il linguaggio delle stelle
o dei venti che sicuramente aiuta i
marinai ad orientarsi e quindi per me
quello era un grande labirinto
e in quel grande labirinto mi sono
sentito smarrito
mi sono sentito fuori dal mio equilibrio
no
la labirintite
non so se sapete cos'è un infiammazione
dell'orecchio anzi di una parte precisa
e l'orecchio che si chiama labirinto
appunto quindi noi abbiamo labirinto
anche all'interno vabbè questo ce lo
teniamo anche per dopo
un infiammazione dell'orecchio che crea
appunto un senso di smarrimento perché
quel diciamo quell'organo lavoro sul
nostro equilibrio e sulla nostra postura
quindi sulla nostra posizione dice musi
ed è proprio il senso che noi abbiamo
quando siamo persi da qualche parte in
un labirinto
quindi anche la labirintite ci riporta
qui
ma poi cosa succede
quando sono in questo labirinto
cosa me ne faccio di questo senso di
smarrimento
la prima cosa per rendersene conto
perché io
mi ero ritrovato in quel labirinto avevo
visto di essere in questo labirinto
questo rendermene conto
aveva già fatto la prima differenza
infatti la canzone all'inizio diceva
maggio tuato ammesso a mare inglese no
non c'è bisogna che traduco parliamo
tutti glia lingue maggio trovato amia
insomma reami enzo amarene perdo mi sono
ritrovato
gustiamoci questa parola
in mezzo al mare e in mezzo al mare mi
perdo
ma cosa di labirintico questo mare oltre
al fatto di non darti alcun riferimento
un altro fattore molto labirintico del
mare anzi delle onde del mare perché poi
la canzone dice come le onde del mare no
troppo il pace n aperto le onde del mare
ad un'altra faccenda molto labirintica
secondo me e che si ripetono sempre
uguali
vanno a sbattere quotidianamente sullo
stesso scoglio ogni santo giorno ogni
santo secondo è solo apparentemente
indistinguibili no
questa idea di ripetizione ci porta al
secondo labirinto ma arriviamoci per
gradi perché io qui quando paolo mi ha
chiamato per venire e mi ha parlato del
tema bellissimo io trovo fantastico il
tema del tx di oggi la consistenza
dell'invisibile
la prima cosa a cui ho pensato è stato
il confine gliel'ho detto subito
vorrei parlare del confine il confine ha
molto a che fare con i labirinti ma
arriviamoci per gradi il confine
rappresenta forza in maniera ideale
tutta tutto il mio percorso artistico e
tutto quello che abbiamo fatto con i
nostri progetti musicali perché in
pratica abbiamo provato a decostruire
l'idea di confine abbiamo provato con la
musica è un grande strumento voi sapete
di
interconnessione no
a superare il confine
l'abbiamo fatto anche fisicamente qui vi
racconto un pochettino perché mi trovavo
su quel motoveliero in mezzo all
adriatico abbiamo dice a un certo punto
con la bandadriatica che uno dei
progetti principali con cui abbiamo
indagato le mille rotte del mediterraneo
per trovare dei fattori comuni abbiamo
deciso che per trovarci per trovare
l'identità del nostro gruppo della
nostra musica dovevamo
andare dall'altra parte del mare non
potevamo dirci banda adriatica non
potevamo dirci musicisti da adriatico
se non dopo aver esplorato l'adriatico
allora abbiamo dovuto superare una certa
non siamo marinai non lo siamo mai stati
non avevamo nessuna esperienza di mare
ci siamo dovuti imbarcare
abbiamo dovuto superare un limite e
confine il limite veniamo e vedremo sono
molto molto vicini fra di loro per
andare ad incontrare quello che c'era
dall'altra parte noi non sapevamo
cosa avremmo incontrato l'idea era
quella molto semplicemente di incontrare
degli altri musicisti croati e albanesi
sloveni che come noi avevamo voglia di
mettere in gioco la loro musica è di
trovare poi una nuova un nuovo
linguaggio un nuovo modo di fare musica
insieme che partisse dall'esperienza
reciproca dalle tradizioni reciproche
soltanto che quando siamo arrivati in
croazia
sapete come sono ritrovati sono un po
all'inizio che stiano
così tenuti al centro del sud abbiamo
cercato di come dire rompere il ghiaccio
che anche questo è un superamento di
confine nazionale no ma all'inizio ci
siamo trovati in una sorta di vuoto in
cui non succedeva niente abbiamo preso
gli strumenti nelle mani
con questo suonatore di lira croata e
loro chiamano liretta uno strumento
molto tradizionale loro
non sapevamo cosa suonare c'era un po di
imbarazzo anche nei primi momenti di
incontro
eravamo piacere un po come dire
intimiditi dalla cosa
ma lentamente
stando con questo smarrimento
stando in questo spazio vuoto in cui non
stava succedendo assolutamente niente
stando un attimo fermi lì in mezzo al
nulla lentamente
ha cominciato a succedere qualcosa
qualcosa di totalmente
inaspettato
qualcosa di totalmente nuovo qualcosa
che nasceva dal contatto la musica
affari ha facilitato questo contatto la
musica è stata come dire il tessuto
sulla quale noi abbiamo lentamente nota
dopo nota costruito dei passi noi verso
di lui e lui verso di noi che piano
piano hanno portato all'incontro
l'incontro non è una cosa scontata quali
incontra una cosa da costruire una cosa
in cui creare ecco in quel momento noi
abbiamo capito
che il confine segna uno spazio molto
preciso fra quello che già conosciamo
di noi e del mondo e quello che non
conosciamo
in quel momento abbiamo capito che
questo spazio che sta oltre il confine
oltre questa linea invisibile che in
realtà siamo noi stessi a disegnare
perché non esiste e straordinariamente
consistente nella sua invisibilità non è
una linea che sta lì è la linea che
delimita la nostra rappresentazione del
mondo ma cosa c'è al di là della nostra
rappresentazione del mondo c'è tutto lo
spazio non conosciuto che lo spazio
della creatività lo spazio in cui
possiamo creare
quando abbiamo finito quella prova con
ivo
con la sua lira
quando abbiamo suonato insieme quel
brano
sconosciuto inaspettato nato
dall'incontro
ci siamo abbracciati
ci siamo
contattati nel profondo
avevamo scambiato pochissime parole lui
parlava pochissimo inglese ovviamente
niente italiano noi niente croato però
c'eravamo
toccati
e la musica aveva fatto da collante
quello che è successo musicalmente e
umanamente quel giorno non ce lo
dimenticheremo mai e così poi sarebbe
successo anche in altre situazioni
così sarebbe successo anche con i
musicisti albanesi con i musicisti
sloveni dopo un po avevamo imparato la
grammatica del superamento del confine
dopo un po non avevamo più paura di
trovarci di fronte al vuoto perché poi
di quello si tratta
e godersi lo smarrimento
godersi quell'istante in cui sono in
mezzo al niente
il fatto di stare lì è diventato la
nostra grammatica
andiamo lì e poi vediamo che succede è
fantastico
noi siamo portati diciamo a prevedere un
po tutto a controllare un po tutto anche
oggi venendo qui ho scritto una parte
dell'intervento ma una parte o lasciata
libera ho detto poi vedo che succede
perché io sto parlando con voi no mi
lascio sempre uno spazio aperto perché
so che in quello spazio
può nascere qualcosa che mi sorprende e
forse anche vi può sorprendere
nel ringraziare tutti di questo invito
mi sono divertito moltissimo
vi lascio con questa semplice idea che
forse anche un augurio ed è frutto di
un'esperienza diretta non è soltanto
un'idea è un'idea che abbiamo messo in
pratica diverse volte
e che ci ha segnato una strada perché a
differenza delle onde del mare
noi non possiamo sbattere lo scoglio a
mani nude tutta la vita dobbiamo uscire
da quella ripetizione e cercare qualcosa
in uno spazio sconosciuto in uno spazio
creativo che sta al di là del limite che
noi disegniamo per noi stessi quindi
l'augurio che vi faccio stasera per
chiudere
è quello di perderli per poi ritrovarmi
grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]